what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some new developments in the
case of Jonathan Majors today if you are
not aware and caught up Jonathan Majors
who plays King the Conqueror in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe was arrested
on March 25th New York City after the
police responded to a 9-1-1 call from a
lower Manhattan apartment where a female
who was Jonathan majors's girlfriend at
the time had bruises on her head neck
and finger we also have learned that
this person this female did work on the
set of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
as well which is where they presumably
met Majors was arraigned on multiple
accounts of assault in the third degree
three counts of attempted assault in the
third degree one count of aggravated
harassment in the second degree and one
count of harassment in the second degree
and this alleged victim was granted a
restraining order against Jonathan
Majors now the reason we're covering
this at all is because this could deeply
affect the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because Marvel Studios might recast
Jonathan Majors as King in fact right
now they have held off and postponed and
might have even canceled the Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania assembled Disney
plus special they have delayed this
indefinitely most likely due to the fact
that they are waiting to see what
happens in court with Jonathan Majors
well Jonathan majors has finally
appeared in court in person and the case
has essentially now truly begun we
thought he was supposed to meet in court
last week apparently that date did get
moved and they met today June 20th and
we have an update on what exactly is
happening and a time frame which is good
to know because that'll tell us kind of
when Marvel Studios will make their
decision on whether or not to recast
King the Conqueror now what's
interesting is that we have San Diego
Comic-Con coming up where we thought
Kevin feige might give us a little bit
of an update on what exactly is going to
be happening here however the new court
date for the trial to officially begin
doesn't start until after San Diego
Comic-Con and perhaps that is for the
better perhaps San Diego Comic-Con
should be focused on really positive
things we're expecting actors to come
out from TV shows and movies to talk
about their upcoming projects and we're
expecting a phase six full reveal so we
already have a lot going on so Kevin
feige most likely won't address this
especially since the court decision will
not be decided until months after so
today he appeared in court for the first
time in person and it was basically for
him to be read the charges that are
being pressed against him which we
mentioned already in this video so
Jonathan Majors showed up to court was
read all the charges against him and
they were given a court date for the
trial to actually begin which is August
3rd that is when the actual trial begins
in Manhattan so this is where evidence
is going to be presented by both sides
now not much has really been said about
any type of evidence that the alleged
victim has but quite a lot has been said
about Jonathan majors and the evidence
that he has against her claiming that he
is innocent in fact when the lawyers met
up his lawyer Priya Chaudhry presented
quite a bit of evidence on Jonathan
majors's behalf in fact one of the first
statements that she put out and has put
out again recently is Jonathan Majors is
completely innocent and is provably the
victim of an altercation with a woman he
knows that's a very interesting and kind
of a powerful statement because she says
that he is completely innocent not just
innocent but completely innocent not he
did some of the things but most of it's
a lie she says completely innocent and
then she says that it is provable which
is obviously a huge thing in court
provable that he is the victim now we
have heard reports that it was actually
Jonathan Majors who called the cops
what's also really interesting is that
Jonathan majors's team has provided
video footage and photos of the alleged
victim out at a a nightclub partying
after the alleged assault took place it
was then reported that Jonathan Majors
then came home later on that night and
found the woman passed out drunk in his
apartment they have also shared text
messages that were from the woman
stating that she didn't mean for any of
it to happen and that she told the
police that he didn't do anything and
that she didn't want anything to happen
to him so there's been quite a lot
presented on the behalf of Jonathan
majors and not so much publicly released
on the behalf of the alleged victim but
that is what this next court date is
going to be about on August 3rd Jonathan
Majors lawyer will go up and try to
prove that he is innocent and the
opposing team will try to prove that
their client was assaulted by Jonathan
majors and again the reason that we are
covering this is because it could
drastically affect the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Marvel's promotions for Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania do not really
feature Jonathan majors at all in fact
all they say is Jonathan Major's name
under credits when talking about the
film on Disney Plus in the description
or anywhere else they don't mention Kang
the Conqueror they simply mention a
threat and he is not on the poster for
the movie that they display either and
here's what has happened to Jonathan
major so far since this has all taken
place since the charges were filed
against him he has lost quite a bit he
has been dropped by his publicity team
the lead company and his management
company as well entertainment 360. and
according to indiewire.com he's also
been dropped by a protagonist pictures
for the role that he was going to play
in their adaptation of the Walter Mosley
novel a man in my basement so he's
already lost one movie role there he's
also been dropped from a Texas Rangers
ad campaign and a U.S army ad campaign
featuring him as well although they
declare that it is simply paused until
the final verdict of the Court decision
is had so the Army came out and
basically stated what is the law
innocent until proven guilty so they
said they simply have paused that ad for
now and if he is proven innocent then
they will continue with the ad so the
sad reality is Jonathan majors has
already suffered from this now we are
remaining neutral we do not know if he
is innocent or if he is guilty in this
situation but regardless it does put
Marvel Studios right now in a very hard
position and basically right now they
essentially do have to make a decision
on whether or not to recast Jonathan
Majors as king and here's the deal
unfortunately even if he's proven
innocent that doesn't necessarily mean
he is in the clear with Marvel Studios
simply because all of the negative
attention that he is getting and the
fact that he was arrested and this trial
is happening that might be enough for
the studio to say hey I'm sorry but we
have to drop you because there's now a
negative connotation associated with you
but at the same time we have seen things
happen like over at Warner Brothers with
Ezra Miller and all of the trouble that
they got into and they decided that they
were going to keep Ezra Miller as The
Flash and continue on with the Flash
Film so hopefully Marvel Studios is
simply waiting to see what the court
decision is going to be if Jonathan
Majors team presents a lot of viable
evidence that is undisputable and he has
proven innocent perhaps he could
continue on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as Kane the Conqueror and if he
truly is innocent hopefully that is
indeed what happens because he shouldn't
suffer if it is a false claim however if
he has proven guilty then of course they
will more than likely drop him I really
don't foresee them keeping him on as
came to conquer if he has proven guilty
in this case in which he will probably
also go to jail so that's pretty much
100 guarantee if he is proven guilty we
will have a new actor playing Kane the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but we'll have to wait and see
what happens in court the next court
date in the first official court date of
him appearing in person is August 3rd it
probably won't be decided that day there
probably will be a few court dates
before they reach the final verdict but
of course if we hear anything at all
we'll be sure to update you so be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos don't forget to like it
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items winner gets to pick one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month we also have a patreon
account now a Discord server and a
website don't forget to check those out
and you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign